well our speaker tonight is a keen
observer of the ongoing battle between
socialism and freedom in Latin America
she is a member of the editorial board
at The Wall Street Journal where she
writes editorial columns on Latin
America trade and international
economics
she is also editor of the weekly column
the Americas which focuses on Latin
America and Canada she is the recipient
of numerous awards for her work
including the Walter Judd Freedom Award
from the fund for American Studies the
Thomas Jefferson Award from the
association of private enterprise
education and the Basquiat prize for
journalism from the international policy
Network would you please welcome to the
podium Mary Anastasia
O'Grady
[Applause]
good evening thank you Tim for that very
generous introduction
it's really a thrill for me to be here
with Hillsdale tonight you know growing
up in New York all the Irish are big
Notre Dame football fans most of those
fans didn't go to the school and a lot
of them have never been out of Brooklyn
but they used to call themselves the
subway alumni because they were so into
Notre Dame football and by extension the
school that's a little bit how I feel
about Hillsdale I didn't have the
privilege to attend the school but I'm a
big fan and I like to consider myself
the subway alumni so it's it's really
great honor to be here tonight now the
title of my talk is socialism in Latin
America but that's a little vague so I'm
going to reframe it with a title lessons
from Latin America how the triumph of
bad ideas has poisoned the well of
prosperity now I'm always a little bit
amused when I talk to Americans who
don't know that much about the region
and the United States tends to look east
west not north south so people generally
don't know about the region it's kind of
a black box for them but there are some
fashionable explanations for Latin
American under development there are
things like corruption lack of education
poor infrastructure and my favorite a
shortage of money which i think is
called poverty but let's be honest all
of these things corruption lack of
education poor healthcare infrastructure
even poverty are symptoms of something
else and that something else is bad
policy and that policy I think can be
best summed up by what I call the three
P's
of populism that is I'm sorry the three
P's of poverty and that is populism
protectionism and prohibition these are
the things that we proponents of Liberty
often find ourselves talking about when
we struggle to make things better in the
region how to open markets how to keep
politicians from making us all
dependence of the state and of course
how to change the drug laws so that
organized crime doesn't keep growing and
overwhelming our institutions but I am
increasingly convinced that we're still
very far from the source of the troubles
and the under development Latin America
when we address threats to Liberty and
progress in this way the three P's of
poverty populism prohibition and sorry
the three populism prohibition and
protectionism are but symptoms of
something that I think is a much bigger
problem in the region and I think
threatens Liberty in the US and in
Europe as well so I ask you to focus on
two things first to borrow a fundamental
principle of classical liberals ideas
matter and I don't mean only their
existence matters but what I mean is
which ideas prevail in society which
ideas are considered legitimate and
moral secondly I want you to consider
the fact that without entrepreneurship
without producers who make things and
sell them and in the process earn a
profit a society
not achieve prosperity I'm going to
argue here tonight that it is bad ideas
from academia and from intellectuals
more broadly that have played the key
role in undermining the entrepreneurial
culture in Latin America over the past
century it's bad ideas that are hostile
to entrepreneurship that have moved from
the intellectual sphere to government
institutions the popular culture and
society more broadly that have eaten
away at the region's promise the ideas
that hold profits are morally and
ethically suspect ownership is not
justified self-determination is selfish
these ideas strike at the heart of all
that human beings ought to hold dear the
right to the fruits of one's own labor
the right to self-discovery and
self-determination and even the right to
fail this thinking has deprived hundreds
of millions of Latin Americans of the
most basic human rights of life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness and it has
undermined their hope for prosperity so
how did this happen in Latin America
after all the 19th century was a time of
more or less classical liberalism in the
region well I will begin with a famous
quote and those of you who are
economists in the room know it well from
John Maynard Keynes in which he
described the power and influence of
intellectuals he said the ideas of
economists and political philosophers
both when they are right and when they
are wrong are more powerful
then as commonly understood indeed the
world is ruled by little else practical
men who believe themselves to be quite
exempt from any intellectual influence
are usually the slaves of some defunct
economist madmen and authority who hear
voices in the air are distilling their
frenzy from some academic scribbler of a
few years back I am sure that the power
of vested interests is vastly
exaggerated compared with the gradual
encroachment of ideas now latin
americans didn't understand this until
it was too late and it is where we north
of the Rio Grande too will lose out if
we don't pay attention to the importance
of making the moral case for the market
does not exist in Latin America Latin
Americans is probably most of you know
have no problem being entrepreneurial
immigrants to the US have long histories
of starting their own businesses once
they've landed in the u.s. so how come
this doesn't happen at home I submit to
you that's because intellectual forces
in the region have been and still are
hostile to entrepreneurship
Enrique Crossy is the Mexican historian
he wrote a book on the history of ideas
and power in the region in the late 19th
century and throughout the 20th century
the book is called Redeemers the book
Profiles twelve individuals who Kraus
they believe represent the major
political ideas in the region from the
middle of the nineteenth century through
the 20th century the book begins with
Jose Marti and ends with ago Chavez it
includes profiles on Ava Peron
che guevara Gabriel Garcia Marquez was a
Colombian writer and friend of Castro
Bishop Samuel Ruiz who was a Catholic
bishop in the south of Mexico during the
Zapatista uprising and soup comandante
DeMarcos who is also part of the
Zapatista uprising in the 1990s in the
south of Mexico
the overwhelming ideology of the period
is collectivist these individuals
Crowley tells us to find the most
influential ideas of their time those
ideas rose to prominence and formed the
intellectual framework that then
supported the region's secular
institutions now there were during this
whole time risk takers entrepreneurs
innovators builders and merchants in
Latin America they were around somewhere
but it was the ideas of these guys who
hated capitalism profits and private
ownership that molded the norms and
values of the laws in these countries I
should note that Krauss a also includes
Mario Vargas Llosa and Octavio Paz and
Redeemers their to individuals who began
on the Left but slowly gravitated toward
classical liberalism but they're the
oddballs in the group and I think but
agasi us in particular is included for
his opposition to military dictatorship
the power of ideas was well understood
among intellectuals on the left
throughout the 20th century in Latin
America they made it their business to
get control of academia and they
succeeded and in the classroom a new
narrative emerged it gave the moral high
ground to the state and denounced the
market as immoral
millions of Latin American students have
been marinated in the values of the left
of central economic planning and state
redistribution but what is more
important to understand is they absorbed
it not purely as economic doctrine but
as the morally legitimate framework for
society this has had a profound effect
on the political climate in the region
as Krauss a shows and Redeemers an
intellectual movement opposed to
classical liberalism mainly because it
was associated with the US and and he
discusses the roots of that being the
spanish-american war the u.s. victory in
the spanish-american war and in favor of
something that he calls Latin American
nationalism began to crop up in the
earliest years of the 20th century
nationalisms economic counterpart
socialism was given a huge boost in the
Great Depression
that's because the smoot-hawley Tariff
hit the region very hard in Latin
American policymakers retaliated by
closing Latin American markets for those
who had resisted nationalism and
socialism until then u.s. protectionism
made it more and more difficult not to
give in now you may say ok well but
today the ideas of Che Guevara and Ava
Peron are discredited and I agree modern
socialists and by this I mean those who
reject communism and fascism but favor
collectivism in some form do not attack
private enterprise head-on that would be
suicidal
because the market has created so much
prosperity and I think there's a wide
recognition of that Arthur Selden
outlined just how defeated the
Socialists were on a practical level by
the end of the 20th century in his
great book the virtues of capitalism
Selden you'll recall was the brains
behind the Thatcher Revolution here's
what Selden said about the relationship
between capitalism and progress the
supreme task humanity is faced down the
centuries has been to discover and
mobilize the abilities talents and
genius of individuals in the creation of
civilized society the rationale and
vindication of decentralized initiative
independent of the state described
popularly as private enterprise
historically as capitalism and
technically as the market economy is
that has proved more effective with
better results in living standard than
any other system from the benign mixed
economy of social democracy to the
rigorous centralized planning of
communism now that's pretty tough to
argue with and the intellectuals in
latin america do not try to argue with
it they know that that would be too
difficult and it's widely recognized
that the market has delivered a lot of
goods but they do not surrender
instead they ask young people to look
not at the wealth of nations but instead
of what they call the morality or
perhaps more accurately the immorality
of the inequality produced by liberty
this issue of equality is the single
most insidious ideology in the region
right now for socialism it's the soft
underbelly of the market economy
Latin America can show us what happens
when the morality the market is not
defended and here is where there are
even lessons for the US and and this is
something that you will notice if you
look at Chile today which has moved from
an underdeveloped country to developed
country in 30 years it created enormous
prosperity but even if a society makes
economic gains by adopting Pro market
policies if the population is not
convinced of the morality of the system
that did this for them it will say if
it's not convinced that the system is
ethical let me put it that way that the
system is fair that it's ethical it will
want to destroy what it has achieved
even if it has achieved great prosperity
in Chile in the recent years where the
Communist Party has been behind student
demands for free university education
and claiming that those who won't give
in to that demand are immoral the
behavior of the students is easy to
understand they want something for
nothing it's sort of run-of-the-mill
rent-seeking but what about the broader
support that they get from Chilean
society Chile's made massive economic
gains and well-being but the society has
been supporting the students and I think
this is because of the fact that the
establishment has not been able to
defend the market economy and to unpack
the connection between entitlements and
the loss of Liberty save for a few brave
intellectuals most of the country's
leadership has been back on its heels
apologizing for the market model because
of the inequality and this is Chile the
poster child of liberal ideas and values
and
prosperity outside of Chile things are
even worse and I blame a lot of this on
the link between intellectuals and
constitutions in most of the region
intellectuals bought this idea of
equality as the highest goal from their
ivory towers they brought it to big
government through the regions
constitutions these constitutions which
are perpetually rewritten by academics
and the intellectual elite always strive
to make state-sponsored equality the law
and of course who can object to making
the poor child equal to the wealthy
entrepreneur the problem with the
Constitution written with the objective
of creating equality of outcomes is that
it cannot guarantee individual rights
and that means that the world that
Arthur Selden described that world of
glorious prosperity is not possible
because you cannot have it both ways
latin-american constitutions are
hundreds of pages long
they have objectives like guaranteeing
National Development eradicating poverty
and substandard living conditions
reducing social and regional
inequalities and promoting well-being
the 1988 brazilian constitution gave
citizens the constitutional right to
education health work leisure security
social security protection of motherhood
and childhood and assistance to the
destitute the Constitution guaranteed
rights to minimum salaries year-end
bonuses overtime and vacation pay it
guaranteed free assistance for children
and dependents from birth to six years
of age in daycare centers and preschool
facilities the culture section of the
1988 Brazilian Constitution charged the
government worth protecting
Brazil's cultural heritage by means of
inventories registers vigilant monument
protection decrees expropriation and
other forms of precaution and
preservation in the section dedicated to
sports yes there's a section dedicated
to sports in the Brazilian Constitution
it specified that the government shall
encourage leisure as a form of social
promotion if you look at the
unemployment rate I think they're doing
a pretty good job now if you think about
all the since trying in the Constitution
you can easily see that the government
has not only the power but the
obligation to use coercion to reach its
goals this is the fundamental cause of
Latin American under development there's
a lack of Liberty of the kind
Arthur Selden describes which emanates
from constitutional mandates aimed at
equality not under the law but equality
of outcomes which intrude on every
aspect of human action now let me just
say one quick thing about special
interests because I do not hold them
blameless
even though Kane's kind of downplayed
their importance what I've been
describing here originates with the
intellectual class but it's also clear
that these ideas might not have gained
so much influence if not for the
business and communities enthusiasm to
join in the game isn't that always what
happens its interests were of course
purely pragmatic let's take Venezuela
the 1961 Venezuelan Constitution was by
most accounts a reasonably sound
document but that didn't mean that
factions as Madison might have called
them didn't have reason to try to pick
it apart and they did for 40 years the
Constitution was under assault
particularly private property of course
the left wanted to undermine the rule of
law and property rights but the business
community helped here's what the late
Venezuelan journalist Carlos
wrote about the slow deterioration of
property rights in the 1961 Constitution
this is a quote many in the business
community did not rebel against growing
state intrusion because they saw it was
easier to convince one cabinet minister
than a market of consumers I'll never
forget watching Venezuelan businessman
cheering the nationalization of foreign
oil companies not realizing that the
politicians would soon come after them
with more controls regulations and taxes
and as we know the government of Olga
Chavez and now Nicolas Maduro
subsequently has done much worse so I'll
just conclude by saying when the state
gets the moral high ground in matters of
personal decisions and property rights
there is no end to the steps it will
take to contain Liberty in the name of
social justice and equality once this
happens standard of living standards of
living will necessarily decline thank
you
[Applause]
take questions Thank You mrs. O'Grady we
now have time for a few questions please
raise your hand and the microphone will
be brought to you
thank you how does religion affect
economics in Latin America
well let's take Cuba for example there
is no religion in Cuba
it's an atheist state the communist
government actually worked to out outlaw
religion in 1959 when they took over so
in a case like Cuba I guess you could
say that it that there were certain
members of the church that tried to
fight back during the Revolution they
were either killed or exiled so at this
point it doesn't really have much of an
effect the church has been trying to get
back into Cuba in my opinion making too
many concessions to the regime but with
the idea that that they would have a
chance to have some open spaces and
minister in Venezuela the church has
been very strong against Chavez and
Maduro and mother they have openly been
fighting with the regime
last good friday a bunch of thugs
working for the regime burst into the
cathedral and started beating people up
so there you have a big conflict between
the church and the government it's hard
for me to just sort of do a blanket
statement about the whole region I mean
there's some more competition and
religion than there was a hundred years
ago in Latin America there's the
evangelical churches have made big
inroads but it hasn't seemed to make a
big difference I mean there's quite a
bit of competition in Central America
between the church and Protestant
denominations in Central America but the
but it hasn't changed the politics very
very much there is a theory held by you
know most famously Max Weber that the
Protestant colonies developed better
than the Catholic colonies because of
Catholic views of economics and
development but I'm not entirely
convinced of that theory a very good
book to read on that is empire of the
Atlantic which talks about the
similarities and differences between the
US and Latin America during colonial
times I I guess I would say one other
thing which is Liberation Theology which
was a Catholic was was a let's see was a
Catholic idea coming but not not
sanctioned by the church in Central
America I think was very bad for the
region and because the liberation
theology is backed Marxism basically and
so I think pretty early on john paul ii
spoke out against liberation theology
and and sanctioned those priests but you
know there's one theory that says that
the the catholic church has a more
collectivist view of the world but if
you read the Scholastic's i don't think
that's true so it's open to
interpretation and it's rather long
discussion but anyway I hope that helps
a little bit I'm sure you know about
Francisco marroquín University in
Guatemala I'm just wondering if you've
seen any influence from that school
which is very much a free-market school
sort of an anomaly in Central America
have you seen much influence from that
school in the reason thank you um it's
kind of interesting because I think the
idea of the founders of the motto Keane
the motto Keane is a University in
Central America founded in the 1970s by
a guy who saw the kinds of problems I
described here with academia basically
control the left controlling all of
academia started this University
wonderful amazing place full disclosure
I have an honorary Doctorate from them
but they've done a fantastic job I they
have not yet had an influence and I
think if you talk to the people from the
university they will say that the idea
of the university is to to develop the
human capital so that when the
opportunity is there like what happened
in Chile in 1973 I mean if you go back
to Chile in 1973 the University of
Chicago had already been working with
Catholic University in Santiago for many
many years
Ted Schultz I think was the originator
of that idea and arnold harberger was
working there so they had the human
capital in place so when Pinochet came
along he basically told the technocrats
look I'm here to defeat communism but I
don't know anything about the economy
and then he kind of let them put in
place the things but they had the human
capital that they needed so the idea
that mano keen is to create that human
capital thus far it seems like most of
the motto keen graduates are very
entrepreneurial so they don't go into
government but I think that's the
long-term hope in Guatemala that that
that they're sort of developing that
over time
thank you I your comment about the
intellectuals of the last hundred 120
years
I think it's right on and I think we the
developed world exported that with the
progressives but I'd like you to address
just the absolute chaos when they threw
off the Spanish yoke
the authoritarianism of the Spanish
rulers that built no civil institutions
doesn't that doesn't that play a more
significant role in my mind then didn't
you give it credit for two so what's
going on with this authoritarian
viewpoint in society now yeah thank you
that's a very thoughtful question I
guess the reason why I don't give it as
much play as you're suggesting is
because if you look country by country
through the region there are glimpses of
institution building and moments when
let's take Argentina for example has a
very big British influence and it had
institutions at one time those
institutions didn't hold up and I have
spent the last 25 years of my life
trying to figure out why they cannot
build institutions I mean because that's
precisely what they need I I agree with
you but there are two problems with
blaming the sixteenth century and one of
them is that you never get out of the
problem
you know we're here now and we're trying
to figure out how do we build
institutions and every time you try to
build the Institute like you try to
write a new constitution you end up with
a mess you end up with a four hundred
page document and with all these kinds
of privileges and so why can't we build
institutions I mean
we can't erase those 400 years that's
what this is where we are so what I'm
trying to discuss here is why the the
Constitution grows out of the norms and
values of a culture and you know the
United States has a lot to be proud of
but we can also say that we had many
moments in time when we were just lucky
and so we with that luck and the right
institutions we made it through that
period of under development to
development so part of the problem is
that development takes a long time and I
think sometimes we expect it to happen
too fast but I think fundamentally at
the very core of it is why don't people
hang on to the things that are in place
why do they let go of them so quickly
when they hit a bump in the road and I
think that has to do with the norms and
values of the culture and I think that
those come about through the the ideas
of the intellectuals and academia I mean
in Venezuela if you talk to Venezuelans
they will tell you that the left was
sort of threatening in the way that the
hard left was threatening the country
since the 1960s so what the politicians
decided to do was say okay you know what
we'll do we'll just give them education
get them out of our hair we can go back
over here and have all the other
ministries we'll just let them over
there and I'll pay attention to them
well of course precisely where they
shouldn't have been and I think like I
said I spent 25 years looking at this I
really think that if there's any hope
for the region to change it has to be
through through the education and when I
say education I'm not talking about
reading and writing because you can the
left does that I mean Cuba's one of the
most literate places in the world it has
to be through the fostering of these
kinds of ideas in the culture and that
just doesn't exist in the real
and it's very rare but I guess EOC is an
exception over here oh sorry
disoriented it's so good to hear you
speak again I saw you speak at Hillsdale
I think the last time this conference
was offered there on that campus maybe
10 12 years ago and over the last two
days we've heard now heard three
speakers speak against free trade and I
know Hillsdale has this great tradition
even on their material of defending
Liberty since 1844 so I ask you do you
think personal liberty is aligned with
free trade or is it okay if we set free
trade aside and have some america-first
policy
well as I mentioned in the beginning of
my talk protectionism is one of the
three P's of poverty and you can you can
trace the impoverishment both material
impoverishment and intellectual
impoverishment in Latin America to
smoot-hawley in the 20th century and the
reverse is also true
you know one of the most successful
countries in the region in the last ten
years is probably Peru you don't hear
much about it it was a very poor country
it was ravaged by The Shining Path but
the one thing that Alberto Fujimori did
when he came in in the 1990s was he
opened the markets
I mean dramatically and it for any of
you who read Spanish there's a very good
book by Jaime de Laos called them the
capitalist revolution all about the way
Peru changed when they open markets
there and you know when you watch this
big wave of left-wing populism that
occurred after Hugo Chavez came to power
in 1999 and you think about the
countries that had hit in the region it
did not hit Peru Peru even elected a
very left-wing guy by the name of a
young Tamala
that people were terrified this guy was
going to be another Chavez but he wasn't
and I think the big difference is that
Peru is a very open economy as is Chile
which continued to grow even through
this coalition that Michele bascially
had with the Communist Party and the
reason is because of of the the openness
so I mean you asked me your question was
sort of whether I think I think your
question had a moral component to it
which is do people have the right to
free exchange and of course I believe
they do but just from a policy and
development point of view I think
opening markets is one of the probably
the single most important thing that can
be done because you don't just get the
trade of goods but you get the exchange
of ideas and that certainly explains why
Mexico has done so well not in its GDP
growth but
in the changes that it's gone through
since 1994
basically a bloodless revolution you
know bringing down the Prix and
converting to a democracy and so forth I
think a lot of that is explained by
NAFTA
[Applause]
I have two questions one personal and
one future isn't the personal one is
where are you from originally I was born
in Philadelphia Philadelphia better
stylist when you're no excuse me I think
yes the future is the question is where
and when do you think an american-style
Republic or society will take root in
Latin America first
hmm well that's kind of a trick question
because when you say american-style I
mean can I can I go with just a
prosperous society as opposed to
american-style because I'm not so sure
the american-style is gonna fit anywhere
every country is going to kind of come
up with their own ideas for example if
you think about Ireland Ireland was a
very poor country and it was a Catholic
country two things that supposedly we
you know Latin Americans are told they
can't overcome because they're Catholic
and they're poor and they're gonna be
stuck like that forever but Ireland has
changed a lot so when you say American
style I mean Ireland is a parliamentary
government but I think you're talking
about property rights and the rule of
law and so forth you have that someone
in Chile and I would say the other
country that I'm somewhat I'm going out
on a limb here but somewhat optimistic
about providing that the that our
current occupant of the White House
doesn't undo NAFTA I think Mexico is is
promising I think you know a lot of the
stuff you don't hear about it because
the war on drugs is kind of like
overwhelmed the news but they're doing
they've done some very serious reforms
in telecommunications and in energy that
show they're serious about property
rights and and they're also a very open
economy at this point I mean if Donald
Trump decides that he doesn't want to do
business with Mexico they're gonna start
doing more trade with countries like
Argentina and Brazil they're very
committed to that model so a lot can
happen you know they have an election
next year and it's possible that Lopez
Obrador could win that election because
they do not have a runoff so all he has
to do is have a majority and he could
win and that would be bad for the
progress of the country I don't think it
would entirely set it back the way
things have been set back in Venezuela
but it would be bad for
the development but those are probably I
think the two most most promising places
first of all I love your column and
nonsubscribers to the WSJ subscribe to
the WSJ to read you but second i want to
kind of push the question of the
relationship between religion in the
free market if you're a jp2 or Benedict
Roman Catholic then you can look at
those Pope's and say follow them and
have economic prosperity I am a
Protestant but so I don't have a dog in
the hunt but as an observer I would say
that that's not that the same with Pope
Francis and so if if Roman Catholics in
South America especially are looking to
an Argentine Pope to give guidance
wisdom and counsel about economic policy
we have somebody who in laudato si
actually railed against the the horrors
of air conditioning so could you give
some this is kind of a follow-up to the
first question of what should Roman
Catholics in South America think about
their Pope visa V economics and and what
does it say about the prospects for the
region in terms of economic growth with
our current Pope thank you well I keep
telling myself that the Holy Spirit had
something in mind when he chose this
Pope we just it's one of one thing we
Catholics call a mystery another mystery
you know I I mean I'll be honest with
you I think this Pope has not been good
for for the region he's not been good
for Cuba I mention I think I mentioned
that before on the ground though I think
there's something different like in
Venezuela I mean I think the Venezuelan
bishops have really stood up I think
they came to the game late and basically
most Catholic clergy over the years in
my lifetime anyway
have not been very good economists so
yeah I think I think you know this Pope
in particular I would say is an example
of what I was talking about in terms of
the morality issue you know because you
can make all the arguments you want
about producing wealth and so forth but
if underneath it people think that
somehow the system is unethical they'll
they'll end up destroying it and so I
would have to agree that he's not good
for the for the region but I but I also
know that for example if you take a
country like Colombia I mean this is a I
don't think the government there is
particularly religious you know I mean
their their Catholicism is sort of a
nominal religion in most of these
countries at this point but and there's
also a very strong wing of Orthodox
Catholics in particularly in places like
Chile and but throughout the region
those people tend to be very free market
so there's a little bit of a of a tug of
war going on there that's the best I can
say without getting excommunicated
it's the teacher again I'm over here
okay sorry teacher again I've learned
from my students that there is sort of a
caste system that from Mexico they think
they are better than the Hondurans
who think they're better than the El
Salvador's now they have that just
reverse but the Mexicans think they are
hot stuff and then you go down and they
think the other groups are not as good
is this based on the economy and the
progress that had been made in the
countries as far as economics is
concerned yeah I think it is I mean
basically Mexico if you look it from a
point of view the World Bank is a
middle-income country at this point it's
not a poor country and most of Central
America raagh was an extremely poor
country so yeah I think that the pecking
order goes exactly like that in terms of
which countries are richer and those
children from those countries feel like
they're better off I had a friend who
taught in the Los Angeles school system
and she said that she told me that the
Guatemalan children tried to pretend
they were Mexican because that was you
know something considered more high
class I don't know a ton about this
region and so I was talking to my friend
in the history department who is an
expert on Latin America and I was
talking to him about capitalism and
socialism and he said well you know the
legacy there is the dole company coming
in coercively to take and so I was
wondering how much of a role does a
weird crony istic coercive version of
capitalism that has sometimes occurred
played in the maybe the hatred of that
system well gosh that's a pretty big
broad question
one of the problems with someone like
was something like the dole company was
just that and this happened with the
Panama Canal also is that the Americans
who went to work there generally had
better living conditions than the people
the local people who were hired so there
grew up a lot of resentment and like I
said that happened a lot with the Panama
Canal but I think it's also important to
keep in mind that in some of these areas
in the region and of course the history
that story of dole goes way back but if
you fast-forward to today and you look
at like for example some of the mining
companies that have tried to do mining
in Central America where there's very
rich veins of minerals and mining was
the thing that was the engine that
basically began to pull Chile
I mean afterwards they did all kinds of
things but mining was really the
beginning of it and what is mining
required meat requires a lot of
investment so companies go in and they
do mining but in a lot of these towns in
for example in Central America they
still live in a very tribal fashion I
mean there are indigenous people and
there's a there's a hierarchy and if you
all of a sudden go in there with
investment and you start hiring people
and they get jobs and they have money
they don't have the same necessary
loyalty to the head of the tribe they
they basically get freedom because they
start to get economic wealth and that's
one of the reasons why foreign
investment is resented a lot because it
changes the power structure and these in
these small towns so that's just one
example I mean there's a lot of
different examples of what foreign
companies do when they go in there
sometimes they're not good stewards of
the property but many other cases they
are but they're resented because they
they change the dynamics of the
political economy we have time for one
more question
the United States in Russia or the
Soviet Union then had the greater
influence on Latin America and South
America both positive and negative as
far as the United States is concerned
what do you think the negative that the
United States has contributed to the
demise of those countries and surely the
no existence of the Soviet Union that it
played before so the question is what
are the negatives of the US policy in
Latin America okay well during the Cold
War
basically the u.s. position was that the
US had a right and a reason to keep the
Soviets out of our backyard
and so I guess the negative would be
that we at some times trying to think
well sometimes we were viewed as as
being on the side of a dictator and that
probably was the case in Nicaragua
because Somoza was our was our friend
and but in the end we ended up pulling
support from Somoza and helping
basically helping Artega and something
similar to that happened in El Salvador
but I think the biggest negative that
the US has played in the region in the
last hundred years has been the war on
drugs in the last 70 years has been the
war on drugs and I say this purely is
from an economic standpoint I mean
there's a huge demand for drugs in this
country there's a prohibition on drugs
which means by definition all of those
billions of dollars have to go into the
pockets of criminals they go into the
pockets of criminals and in very poor
countries who who then can use that
money to basically buy and overwhelming
institutions there's no way that you can
build institutions in that environment
there isn't I mean a lot of people you
know you look at that and you say well
is the answer legalizing drugs I don't
know what the answer is I'm just telling
that went from a practical standpoint
our policy of consuming huge amounts of
drugs and then keeping the prohibition
on it is by definition feeding huge
transnational organized crime in Central
America and it's one of the big barriers
to development thank you very much mr.
cocaine thank you thank you thank you
very much
[Applause]